yeah welcome to this game of five minute
game and I'm doing c4 let's see can we
get an English opening and I'm playing
the so-called Botvinnik set up with c4
and deform you can play the Sun against
various setups King h8 yeah this is
often often useful this is kind of move
again I can just take some always an
option let's play a form so that you
cannot go F for himself controlling the
g four square I want to play Bishop e3
without them getting harassed by Nigel k
just 22 now it looks like I like this
kind of position where every pieces
harmoniously working together okay so
that looks like you wants to go queen
age 5 and then on Knight g4 okay should
I play deform maybe
the issue is c4 but f5 is also very weak
so if he takes e4 I can take a 5-4 k he
doesn't even consider something else
then advancing okay well I cannot allow
him to play t5 so I played to find
myself Knight takes rook tank or pawn
takes your context the sound normal yeah
take what the point yeah you still has
got this Queen age 5 business going
Queen age 594 so not much I can do about
that I can put the bishop here yeah
maybe it's a it's nicely placed on
default night on III maybe it could be
this night only three this one on c3 you
can put this night on d3 but I'm not
sure how problematic this really is
that's some it looks nice but I'm not
sure that it is doing so much
yeah this is a bit annoying if i go here
he can play Knight g4 and then take on
default gather the bishop is some not
protected
okay I'm this isn't this isn't too great
yeah maybe I need to do this anyway yep
right f5 looks very very shaky
yeah not much not much else I'm already
committed to that yeah he's got this
check here maybe you can just play Queen
g7 i have got 94 covering g3 but barely
yeah this is the idea anyway take a fall
and Bishop takes all night eggs maybe
night takes to have g3 covered but it's
i'm pretty sure that black has something
it looks like there should be some some
strong strong rules maybe he can take g3
even Luke g8 check yard looks very
dangerous queen a king edge to Queen a
tragic bush of h3 and then something
green edge form wow it's very very
tricky check
ok at least I only have one move now
okay I he's doing something sameer them
now I need to take yeah i saw that i
couldn't do anything against it but if i
go night before now covering g3 what is
the big idea lots of stuff hanging yeah
i can take with the rook losses problem
it's not even a check i could have taken
default with check ah this was stupid I
mean okay I saw that this wins but the
other one is just easier yeah he he just
sacrificed incorrectly the position was
certainly are very good for black solids
keep it simple black yeah let's check
web like I could have could have one or
got the advantage somewhere here
probably oh cool computer says is equal
now yeah it wasn't 100% sure that I'm
bet here but computer wants to take on
see three years this is necessary then
I'm not I'm not in trouble maybe he
could could do something before so maybe
no Bishop f5
rook e8 look a 28 slight black advantage
John's not it's not too convincing yeah
the problem was I really played them a
bad setup here yeah yeah this isn't
great simply maybe around here i need to
need to improve i don't think that this
is a big issue this position but this
really was a was bad night h5 is not
very good yeah just attacking g3 out I
really played this badly ok thanks for
watching